is the only possible justification for the logic being
the science of logic being also the science of being.
The self-determining content of thought
is structurally identical to the self-determining content
of being.
And so that's why Hegel says in the Encyclopedia,
paragraph 24, the logic coincides with metaphysics.
They have the same content.
Hegel's just told us that the deduction of that science,
the science that is both logic and metaphysics,
is the phenomenology of spirit itself.
And the phenomenology is, let's see, 500 pages?
500 pages, 466.
So that's a little disappointing,
because if you want to know why the science of logic
is actually a metaphysics, if you
want to see the deduction of this science
and its justification, you need to read
the whole phenomenology of spirit.
And every step in the phenomenology of spirit
needs to work.
But I think there's internal evidence.
That's why I assigned those passages
from the Encyclopedia.
There's internal evidence in the Encyclopedia
that Hegel thinks there's a shorter
argument to that conclusion.
Now, that is to say.
So what is the relationship between these two things?
I'm not sure what the relationship between these two
things is.
I think that the argument that I call the short argument
is sufficient to establish the logic
as being what the science of thinking
and the science of metaphysics, the science of thinking
and the science of being what being.
But it won't repel any possible skepticism
as to whether that is knowing, whether it is science,
and whether it is all that science and knowing could be.
That is to say, if you really want
to press Hegel with skeptical objections
about the possibility of a science of logic
slash metaphysics, the following short argument won't suffice.
So there's a passage in the science of logic
that I think indicates that he has something
like the following short argument in mind.
This is at 2134.
On the other side, one can appeal
to the representations typical of ordinary logic.
For it is assumed that in definitions,
for example, the determinations are not just
of the knowing subject, but are rather determinations
of the subject matter, such that constitutes
in our most essential nature.
So the idea is, just like totally ordinary logic,
we assume that when we define a concept,
we haven't just learned something about our concept.
We've learned something about being.
If I say, let concepts be, that's a bad example,
let a bachelor refer to unmarried males.
We've learned both what the concept bachelor is,
and we've learned what bachelors are.
We've learned something about the world,
and we've learned something about our concepts.
And those are two different facts
under two different modes of description.
It's not possible for those things to come apart.
Now, it might be that our concepts
don't carve reality at instruction.
So merely defining might not get you at the structure.
Might be that, as probably as difficult.
Being is not carved up into bachelors in life.
This is not an ontologically important distinction.
But if you can just do ordinary logic,
you can't really entertain skepticism
about whether ordinary logic is truer.
And that means either you can't do logic in ordinary sense,
or ordinary logic is already a guide to being.
Or in an inference drawn from given determinations
to others, the assumption is that the inferred
is not something external to the subject matter
and alien to it, but that it belongs to it instead.
That to the thought, there corresponds being.
So what Hegel has in mind is just
in doing a totally ordinary inference in what is ordinarily
called logic, you have to presuppose you can't entertain
skepticism about, so to speak, the metaphysical importance
of that claim.
So let's just, as simple as possible inference,
I'm not even sure that Hegel considered this inference.
So let's say P, therefore, either P or Q, this is called.
Not necessarily an inference that logicians
in the ordinary sense would accept in Hegel's input.
So let's just back it up.
Now, if you've accepted this as a valid inference in logic,
you've accepted that if P is true, then P or Q is true.
So you've also accepted that if P, then if P or Q. Now, you can't,
as long as you accept this as a rule of inference in logic,
you have to accept that it preserves truth.
And if you accept that it preserves truth,
you've accepted, essentially, a claim about reality.
Because notice, this doesn't say anything about inference or truth.
This is, so to speak, purely metaphysical.
It just makes a claim about the world.
And this is what we do in logic.
So if you can do this, and this is knowing, if you know this,
then you know some things about the world.
And you know them purely.
So either you're a skeptic about this, and then Hegel thinks,
well, now you can't do any science of anything.
You're a real skeptic.
Because you'll be like, oh, here's just another example.
P and Q, therefore, P and Q. I know Hegel was German,
and I know Kant was German.
But I don't know whether Kant was German and Hegel was German.
Now you've just totally made it impossible for yourself
to do science about anything.
So the idea is, just in accepting ordinary logical
inference as preserving truth, you
are accrediting yourself knowledge of the world.
Because that is actually indirectly knowledge
of the world.
Now, you might think that's really trivial formal knowledge
And Hegel will say, that's what you're totally entitled to think
of that until you read my logic.
Because what I'm going to show you
is things even more basic than this develop
really contentful knowledge.
So the idea is this, Hegel wants to get you
on the hook for thinking that there's no, let me just finish,
there's no coherent skepticism about the metaphysical import
of logic.
We can just translate from logical truths
to metaphysical truths, although they're
pretty rinky dinky metaphysical truths so far.
Here's another example.
Can you coherently entertain skepticism
about the law of logic?
There are no true contradictions.
So let's just say the principle of contradiction
is there are no true contradictions.
OK.
Now, if you accept that as a law of logic,
Hegel thinks, you have to accept not merely,
oh, you shouldn't think that there
are any true contradictions.
But there are no contradictory thoughts.
That is to say, anything that's contradictory
isn't actually thinkable.
So the question is, can you entertain the following thought?
There are no contradictory, self-contradictory thoughts.
But maybe the principle of contradiction
is inaccurate about being capitalized.
Is that a coherent thought?
Well, no, Hegel thinks.
Because insofar as you entertain that,
you're entertaining the thought maybe it
is inaccurate to being that there
are no true contradictions.
Well, what's a true contradiction?
It's a contradictory thought.
So to entertain skepticism about the metaphysical import
of the principle of contradiction is self-underbody.
Because you're attempting to hold in your thought.
There are no self-contradictory thoughts.
But maybe there are some true ones.
Now, this presupposes two things.
It presupposes what's called the constitutive conception
of logic.
That is to say, it presupposes that what you find out in logic
is the structure that thoughts have to have.
Not the structure that they ought to have,
but the structure that thoughts as such have.
And that's why it's incoherent to entertain that
and then entertain skepticism of whether it might be some others.
And secondly, the truth is the predicate of thoughts.
Because that's what allowed me to go from there's
true contradictions, there are true contradictory thoughts.
Without that, this argument doesn't work.
Now, this is an oversimplification
because Hegel doesn't really hold this view.
Doesn't really hold the constitutive conception
of logic.
And this is a thing you might think,
maybe Hegel's thought is vulnerable there.
Maybe he's just assuming a certain idealist view.
Namely, that truth is a matter of thought.
But I actually don't think Hegel is vulnerable on that point.
So here's the idea.
The idea is let's see if we can make skepticism
about the metaphysical import of logic coherent
by distancing reality from thought.
We could say, look, there might be contradictions.
It might be the case that P had not P. Even though we have
to think, we can't think that.
There can't be any P and not P thoughts.
So already, you're like, well, what was I doing?
But already, so then, next move, if P and not P is the case,
then isn't it the case that P and not P is true?
So you could reject that.
That's potentially a question.
But then Hegel, I think his question would be,
what are you even talking about?
How could it be the case that this, without it being true?
I think Hegel thinks this is the most trivial thing
in philosophy.
Q if and only if it's true that Q.
The way in which Donald Davidson is a Hegelian.
Although, actually, there was a lecture here years ago
about what kind of idealist is Hegel.
And my objection at one point was, well, if this is right,
then Donald Davidson is an absolute idealist.
And the speaker was like, yes, exactly, Donald Davidson.
That's not right.
Now we're a good friend of mine.
So then the question is, OK.
So that doesn't look, that Hegel looks pretty good then.
The next thing you could say is P and not P is not a thought.
So you might think, OK, look, sure,
we can't think contradictory whatevers.
But truth is not a property of thoughts.
It's a property of something like propositions.
So I just want to know, when Hegel talks about thoughts,
he doesn't mean activities of human spirit.
He means the content of activities of human spirit.
So thought in Hegel, pedanka, is something
like a content of thought in the psychological sense.
So then I want to know, what does this person
mean by a proposition if they don't mean a content of thought?
And if they really mean, oh, the propositions
are not contents of thoughts, then I
have no idea what they're talking about.
And I'm not sure that they know what they're talking about.
So finally, the final source of possible skepticism
about this argument is you might say, oh,
but logic isn't about propositions.
It's just about our thinking.
But then you've saved logic from having
any metaphysical import by making it purely psychological.
It's just about our psychological activities
rather than its content.
So the Hegelian point is there's no pathway
once you accept that we do logic in the ordinary sense,
without which there's no science of anything.
And once you've accepted that logic is not just psychology,
not about the psychological activity of thought
that happens in space and time, so the content of thought,
then you're on the hook for the metaphysical import of logic.
So that's the short argument to the conclusion
that if we can determine non-trivial facts
about the content of thinking as such, any thinking as such,
we will have determined non-trivial facts
about the structure of being.
That is to say, we can go from logic to medical.
Now, this by itself isn't that interesting
if all it gets to you is trivial logical truth.
Very few people would deny that the tautologies
of predicate logic, or tautologies
of propositional logic, are metaphysically necessary.
The Hegelian, what makes this more interesting
is Hegel is going to argue that the structure according
to which thought just as such has to think
is significantly richer and more contentful than just
the tautologies of propositional logic, much less
the tautologies of Aristotelian logic, which are just
like the principle contradiction.
This is the stuff that I went over last time
in a little bit more detail than I went over last.
So here's another thing.
Hegel fundamentally doesn't think of logic in terms of laws.
So we now think of logic as the laws of what is true.
What follows from what?
And then there are some trivial things
that follow from no assumptions whatsoever,
and they're just true.
Those are the laws of logic.
Hegel doesn't really think in those terms.
The logic is much more about determinant thought content.
So we can replace this and make it
a more Hegelian-friendly point if we say not
that which is not self-contradictory thoughts,
but something like there are no thoughts that are not
f not f determinant.
That is to say, f not f marks a joint in logic,
where every thought has to be determinately
on some side of that.
Or another example would be, there
are no thoughts that are not subject predicate thoughts.
But maybe it is inaccurate to being because there
are true thoughts that are not f not f determinant
or, for example, not subject predicate judgments.
So that's more the level at which Hegel is thinking about it.
Once you've accepted that all thought as such
has a certain structure, you cannot then
play the skeptic and be like, but maybe
being self-structured like that, because that
is pretending to think that all thought
is structured a certain way, but certain thoughts that
are not structured that way are true or accurate
to the structure of each.
So at any point in the logic, you're like,
OK, maybe I have to think this way,
but why is being structured that way?
Just reapply this argument.
And if the argument of the logic has succeeded,
that whatever thought structure you're dealing with in the logic
has been imminently derived in such a way
that there's no way of doing without that.
These are not contingent thought contacts
that you can think according to or not as you wish.
They are the structure that thought just as such has to do.
Yeah.
When he says there are no thoughts, such and such,
what does there are means?
If it means that we just were incapable of taking
the thoughts, then that's to reduce the effect
of the sidewalk from the logic.
And if it means there aren't thoughts out there
in this problem, or one of them that
is already assuming some sort of sense of imperialism,
so it's kind of making questions of where you are.
OK, good.
How about thought as such cannot but think fill in the blank?
So then, what is a thought contact?
Something that thought as such can think,
not making any claims of a human thinking.
And if it's possible and logic to prove that thought just
as such has to think in certain ways,
then we're off to the risk.
OK, yeah?
Very simple question because I'm very confused.
So my mental activity, my psychological activity
of thinking in the normal sense, thinking there exists an exercise
that I'd be able to not recognize,
is that not the general decision that people recorded?
OK, yeah.
So your question puts, you're putting your finger
on the question, what is the relationship
between human thinking, an activity that
occurs in space and time, in particular
datable historical moment, have to think it
as the topic of the logic?
And that is not treated in the logic.
That is a thing that at some point in the system,
we have to figure that out.
We have to ask ourselves, at some point in the system,
wait, how do I fit into this?
I'm just a guy in Germany.
I'm finite.
I think sometimes I don't always think,
I haven't been thinking forever, I'm not going to think forever.
What is the relationship between thinking
in the psychological sense to thinking in the logical sense?
And that, of course, that's not just a question for Hegel.
That's a question for everyone who
is not the worst form of psychologist about logic.
What is the relationship between logic and psychology?
Or what is the bearing of logic on thinking
in the psychological sense?
And so if Hegel's system works out properly,
we're going to derive.
We don't yet have in science thinking
in the psychological sense as a topic.
So we have to derive that in science.
There's no who in the logic.
My view of it, your question is, who is thinking the logic?
Who is the subject of the thought of the logic?
Is this the thing that people have different views about?
My view is, that is not a topic of the logic.
That is to say, in logic, we ignore the identity
of the subject of thinking.
As we do in normal logic, take a logic class.
We now call them propositions.
But they're just contents of thinking.
If you then ask, well, what's the relationship
of this to my psychology?
Your logic teacher will say, this is not what we're doing.
I probably assume it's universal thinking.
But find me the logic textbook that
wasn't written in Germany in the 19th century that says,
intro logic.
The topic of this book is universal thinking.
Interestingly, there is one 19th century German
logician who says this.
And it's Frege.
In Der Gedanken, which is one of three essays
called The Logical Investigations that Frege
published late in life after Bertrand Russell had located
a paradox in and thus destroyed his Frege's life work, who
means that's the basic laws of arithmetic.
Frege wrote these three essays trying
to shore up what remained of his life's work in logic.
The thought, or thought, is the most interesting of them.
And he says in that essay that logic is not the study of minds
but of the mind.
This is a question that is not just about the mind.
So Frege, who's supposed to be and is
presented as the godfather of good analytic,
non-psychologistic logic as opposed to all this German
idealist bullshit, in one of the key documents,
says that logic is the science of the spirit, of spirit.
Not of spirits, but of the spirit.
That's a more psychologistic conception of logic than a godfather.
So that's another class that I'll someday teach.
Frege as bad German idealist.
Or why analytic philosophy is, in the Marxist sense,
a deviation of German idealism.
OK.
And then I'll be assassinated by you, Mr. Gritty.
So I just want to emphasize a few things,
because these are things that I'm
worried that you might get the wrong impression about.
One, logic is not about thinking in the psychological sense.
It's not about the activity of human beings thinking.
It's about what thinking just as such has to think.
It's about the content of thinking as such.
Hegel, unfortunately, just uses the word thought for that.
Now, that thought has this bad ambiguity.
It can be both Nick Stang's thought
and what Nick Stang thinks.
It's only the second sense in which we're interested,
the sense in which my thought can be exactly the same as yours.
And we're not interested in the identity of who
or what thinks these thoughts.
Yeah.
So that means, as Hegel says, page three of the handout,
instead of using the expression thoughts,
it would thus be better to speak of thought determinations
and to avoid any misunderstandings.
So what does that mean?
It means that in logic, we study the content of thought.
So what we study is what makes a thought
determinantly the thought it is, namely its content.
Or thoughts are individuated.
They are what they are in virtue of their content,
because what they are is thought content.
Now, he's not saying that everything thinks
or that everything is a thought.
The identity of being and thinking
must, however, not be taken in a concrete sense.
Hence, what is not to say that a stone that has being
is the same as a thinking human being.
He's not saying that a stone is a thought.
He's saying is there might be stones that we can never,
there's going to be facts about stones that human beings can
never know.
There might be physical objects that
are too distant for us to experience.
There may be physical objects that are too far in the past
for us to know about.
But nothing in being can be logically alien to us.
Everything has the structure of thought.
And since the structure of thought
is not these trivial, tautologous things,
like the principle of contradiction,
it's the very determinate, contentful structure
of the logic that is a metaphysics worth calling
the end.
So this science of just the content of what thought
as such as to think will also be the science of being just
as being or being or being the traditional definition
of metaphysics.
Now, everything that we do is a modification of thinking.
So willing is thinking about what to do or what is good,
what is choice worth.
Desiring also is thinking about what you want.
Perceiving is seeing what is the case.
The content of your perception is also
the content of a thought.
You see that the book is on the table.
Hegel thinks that the marker of thought content is is, is being.
So we don't just see objects.
We see that things are the case.
And so the content of perception is also the content of thought.
Thinking can appear to be just one capacity
of one kind of animals.
That's thinking in the psychological sense.
But it can't be just that.
If it were just that, if it were like human vision,
then the following we'd be coherent.
There is an object that we can think about.
There are objects that we can think about.
And there are objects we cannot think about.
Just as there are objects we can see
and there are objects we cannot see.
Or in Aristotelian terms, thought cannot be an organ.
Can't be one capacity among others
that has one characteristic object over others.
Anything that can be is the, and that
means that thinkable is transcendental,
not in the Kantian sense, but in the original sense
in which unity, truth, and goodness are transcendental.
This is traditional doctrine that all beings are one, true,
and good.
That oneness, truth, and goodness are
constitutive of any being.
And they're interconverted.
Thought is transcendental in something like that sense.
All beings just as such are thinkable,
and all thought is about being.
That's why the purported claim, or one
way to get at that point about the transcendental character
of thought is the claim there is something that cannot be
thought is self-undermining.
So if we think of the development
of transcendental philosophy after Kant
as trying to find a master notion such
that what we do in philosophy is we
study how that is possible.
And then there's nothing outside of that.
We can think, OK, in Kant in some way it's representation,
but representation is too broad.
It can't be cognition, because in Kant
there are things we can represent
that we can't cognize, et cetera, et cetera.
There are other possible candidates for the notion.
Some of them aren't going to work.
Like, for instance, Robert Pippin in his most recent book,
The Culmination, which is about Heidegger in relation
to German idealism, thinks Heidegger wins
because the thing that philosophy should really
be about is meaningfulness.
The Deutschland.
There's the small problem that that's not what being is.
All that taric decay makes that point.
But Beidouitzamkite, meaningfulness,
is not a plausible candidate for our fundamental access
to everything, because the following
is perfectly coherent.
There are things that are not meaningful to me.
So there's something beyond the realm of Beidouitzamkite.
So if we want to study the fundamental way in which
human beings are onto something, or about stuff,
or represent things, use Kantian terminology,
that which is meaningful to us is not a good starting point.
Because we can obviously be onto or intentionally
relate or represent or think about things that
are not meaningful to us.
There's a lot of stuff that's completely meaningless to me.
That sounded dark.
Whoops, like formal epistemology.
Completely devoid of Beidouitzamkite, but it has been.
The following, however, is self-underbinder.
There is something I cannot think about.
That means that a plausible case can
be made for why the fundamental notion
in transcendental philosophy, the thing that properly
describes human-mindedness relationship to anything
that it can be onto, is not meaningfulness but thinking.
OK.
Now thinking as the activation of a capacity in human beings
does not create, generate, et cetera, being.
It's not that being is a product of human thinking.
It's that any more than human thinking
is the product of the laws of logic.
It's that there's no thinkable distinction
between the structure of the content of thinking as such
and the structure of being.
OK.
Let me just, the first thing, the next thing
I'll go over very quickly is what Kantian logic does,
Hegelian logic correspond to.
In some sense, it's neither of them
because it isn't about a capacity or any capacities
of human mind.
On the one hand, it's more like transcendental logic
because it's about the content above.
But on the other hand, it's also more like pure general logic
because it's about the form of thinking.
But really, it's neither slash both of them
because in studying a form of thinking,
you also uncover all of its content.
So something like pure general logic and transcendental logic
become kind of the same for Hegel with the proviso
that they don't become the same because the content of thought
is provided by sensibility.
And this one logic, which is both transcendental and pure
general, is not about any capacities of the human mind.
OK.
Now furthermore, so the thing in Kant that most closely
corresponds to Hegelian logic is the metaphysical deduction
with the proviso that Hegel thinks of his deduction
of the categories of thought as more systematic or imminent than Kant's.
And there's no separation.
We don't first deduce all of the predidational forms of judgment
and then deduce the categories of thought.
The categories themselves are also predication forms.
So the first category of logic is being.
That's also the most basic form of predication is.
As we'll see next week, it's prior even to the distinction
between subject and predicate.
So each of the categories of the logic is also a kind of predication.
OK.
Skip the historical background.
A lot of this is not particularly important.
OK.
I'm going to skip the stuff about method
because it will come back in a couple of weeks.
OK.
So dialectic, remember, is originally in ancient philosophy
or in ancient philosophical practice the art of reputation.
It's how you, as they say on YouTube, destroy people.
That's all the YouTube videos of like Ben Shapiro destroys liberal.
That's all dialectic.
The worst possible dialectic, although Ben Shapiro
has an undergraduate degree in philosophy, I believe,
his parents should get a tuition, a reimbursement.
OK.
I mean, whatever, he's a sophist.
Sorry, I don't want to pick on Ben Shapiro.
Most so-called public intellectuals, most of public intellectual life
is just sophistry.
It's just using rhetorical skills to make the weaker argument to be stronger.
If you haven't figured this out already, this is some good news.
A philosophy education is the best possible education in sophistry.
We're not teaching you how to be sophists,
but we've given you all the skills necessary for maximal sophistry.
You've already probably figured this out.
Just with a little philosophical training,
you can win any argument with your friends
about things you know nothing about because you know as a philosopher,
you just immediately move the terrain onto something
where knowledge doesn't matter.
And then the classic philosophy move is to be like, well,
I don't know what that means.
And now what you've done is you just all their knowledge
has now been made irrelevant because they actually know what it means.
And you're like, I don't know.
So this is also why philosophy is the best possible preparation for law
school.
So you have all the skills necessary to be a really, really successful
YouTube sophist.
I hope you don't do that with your philosophy training.
So that's what dialectic is originally.
Hegel praises Kant's transcendental dialect.
In particular, the Antinomies, he doesn't really
care about the rest of the dialectic.
He always identifies the dialect with the Antinomies.
Because what Kant discovered is that there's
a dialectic built into reason itself.
That is to say, reason itself generates these contradictions.
The problem is that Kant was too freaked out by his own discovery
and thought, oh, what that shows is we better not
try to cognize the unconditioned in things
themselves using the categories.
Instead, what he should have realized
is that the categories in their fixed determinant relationships
to one another generate contradictions.
That's the dialectic of the categories themselves.
Just those concepts themselves dialectically undermine themselves.
Now, Hegel's conception of dialectic is not,
as we saw in the phenomenology, is not just negative.
It's not just that some set of categories
generate contradictions and therefore undermine themselves.
It also generates, it's also positive, it's also generated.
It generates new categories.
And Hegel's name for this kind of philosophy
or this kind of logic, which works by uncovering,
makes it sound like we're doing something.
But I'm going to say it anyways.
Uncovering contradictions or letting concepts contradict
themselves and then resolve that contradict in a higher concept
is he calls that speculative.
So another way of putting that is Hegel's logic is speculative.
That doesn't mean it's speculative in the way of like,
we don't have really good evidence for what happens
10 to the minus seconds after the Big Bang,
but this kind of seems right.
It's not tentative.
It works by thought context and contradicting themselves
and something resolving that contradiction.
It is in this dialectic as understood here,
and hence in grasping opposites in their unity
or the positive in the negative that the speculative consists.
So that's a foreshadowing of the nature of the contradictions
that will arise in the logic.
The nature of the contradictions that
will arise in the logic is you have two categories that
are defined, or what they are, they're
determinately what they are through their difference
from one another.
One category in the marriage.
This is the negation of C1.
This is the negation of C2.
But it will also prove to be the case that they are the same.
So I have categories that are defined through their difference
like one and many, and then we'll
turn out that the one is many and the many is one.
That's a contradiction.
Now the hard thing will be to see how you resolve that,
because it can't be us being like, oh, I
have an idea how to resolve that.
That would be external.
It would be insufficiently imminent.
Somehow the contradiction has to resolve itself,
or just the thought contents themselves
have to resolve the contradiction that they
themselves are.
So as Hegel says, it is thinking that causes the wound
and heals it too.
So thinking causes its own contradictions and resolves it.
But while going about its business,
it so happens that thinking becomes
entangled in contradictions.
It loses itself in the fixed non-identity of its thoughts.
That's what this.
These things are what they are because of what they are not.
It loses itself in the fixed non-identity of its thoughts
and in the process does not attain itself,
but instead remains caught up in its opposite.
The higher aspiration of thinking
goes against this result produced by thinking satisfied
with merely understanding.
So this structure, where a concept is what
it is through its negative relationship to something else,
is what Hegel identifies as the understanding.
Now, he, along with Kant, he acknowledges a difference
between understanding and reason.
But he thinks Kantian reason, Kantian fernund,
is also locked at this level.
Because Kantian reason just seeks conditions
for given conditioned objects where those conditioning
relations are defined through the categories, which
are themselves fixed in determinant identity.
So this is all Kantian.
This is all what Hegel would call understanding
or what Kant would call reason, including
what Kant would call understanding.
Or another way of putting this is
what Hegel calls understanding, subsumes Kantian understanding
and Kantian reason.
Hegelian reason is what resolves the contradiction.
So this is purely negative, or the negative dialectic.
Now, that means, although the logic is not about understanding
and reason, we can correlate what's
going on in the logic with these mental capacities.
So once again, we have to always distinguish.
Hegel is not, he doesn't just talk
about the topics of one science in the book
that that science is about.
He also talks about other things.
And so you have to be careful to separate them.
So these reasons of understanding
are not properly logical topics.
These are anticipations of his conception
of the capacities of spirit, the capacities of the mind.
I'm going to skip that and talk about with what
must the beginning of science be made.
Questions up to this point.
Yes.
So if you know P, then you know about the world.
But our knowledge is perception, our perception,
and our subject is perception.
So how do we can say if we know P, and P is not perception?
OK, so I think you're running together
two different parts of the Hegelian story.
So not everything we know is through perception,
because the contents of logic is not something
that we can perceive.
However, what we can perceive is thinkable content.
Therefore, it has the logical structure
that will be uncovered in the logic.
You perceive determinate beings.
You perceive them as having qualities.
You perceive them as being one and many.
You perceive them as quantitatively determinate.
You perceive them as being measurable.
You perceive a difference between how they are
and how they appear to you under certain circumstances,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So the deep logical structure of the content of perception
is also provided in the logic, but the topic of the logic
is not that content qua perceivable.
OK, yes.
You said that if you don't want to be like a psychological,
if you want to make logic entirely psychological,
then you have to accept.
But surely the psychological alternative
is like the elephant in the room.
That's the one that I would go to naturally
if I was a skeptic.
So should I just read the phenomenology of spirit?
I think that's Hegel's considered answer.
What he kind of says in the introduction is,
yeah, go study with Frese and stop bugging me.
That is to say, I think Hegel just in the introduction
just has no time for that view.
So Frese is this guy who he's like a Kantian,
but he thinks that Kant's transcendental philosophy
is psychology.
And Hegel has nothing but contempt for that view.
There's a great book about, so one
of the things that happens over the course of the 19th century
is German philosophers periodically go back to Kant
and are like, wait, all the answers were here all along.
Let's just do this.
Let's forget about this fifth The Schelling Hegel stuff.
It's incomprehensible.
And maybe it's falsified by natural science.
There's a great book about the whole thing
by Fred Beiser called The Genesis of Neocontinism.
And that book is basically the history of Kantians being like,
oh, let's make this all about psychology.
And then at some point, they're like, wait.
If it's all about psychology, then it's just
about stuff in space and time.
And so it can't explain how knowledge in space and time
is possible.
And then they're like, oh, I'm not
sure what to do about that.
So it has this slightly dissatisfying quality
of you can see the problem coming
a million times, a million miles away,
and then all of these 19th century
psychologists and neocontians eventually
figure out the thing that was obvious on page one.
Yeah?
Maybe you'll get to this later.
What's then the upshot of me just sitting here
doing regular metaphysics?
What's the upshot?
For Kant, it becomes we're not talking about things
in themselves.
Is there an analogous thing for Hegel?
Oh, you mean what does Hegel think
you're doing if you're just doing spinosistic metaphysics?
Sure.
I think he thinks you are thinking,
but you're not thinking purely.
So some of the content of your thought
will be pure thought content.
And it will get something about the structure of metaphysics
right.
But it won't be scientific.
And so it will be a kind of aggregate of genuinely content
that genuinely reveals the metaphysical structure of being
and then just kind of your opinions and weird stuff.
And so because of his commitments
in the philosophy of history, we have to be able to,
if everything Hegel says is true,
then the content of the science of logic
has to be findable in the history of philosophy.
So in principle, we should be able to go back
through the history of philosophy
and find all of this stuff kind of exploded.
It's like there's a logical explosion.
And all of the shrapnel, all of the broken shards
of the logic bomb have been spread over time.
And this sounds very Dr. Who, but the history of philosophy
is like finding all of them and then reassembling them
into Hegelian logic as a confirmation
that we were right about the whole thing.
Yeah?
What about what's happening now?
Well, that's a really good question, actually.
It's actually a very hard question,
which is, what does Hegel think about the future?
And he doesn't say anything about it.
And so some people think that means Hegel
thinks there's no real future.
It's all just this.
Like, we're done.
And we can just repeat it.
That would be very disappointing.
Some people think that shows that Hegel thinks the future is
radically open.
That's ridiculous.
That's not worth it.
I can't even believe that I have to listen to people say that.
That would mean that the Hegel system has an outside,
or there's some stuff that's outside, which would mean,
OK, it's incoherent at every level.
The thing that people are primarily
concerned with about the Hegel future question
is not logical or metaphysics, but his philosophy of right.
Because those will see we get to the philosophy of right.
Hegel says in the preface of the philosophy of right,
something that seems to say, not we've come to the final form,
but I can only just describe this
because the social system that I'm describing is dead.
It's on its way out.
But then what's next?
And Hegel doesn't say, and the philosophy of history
seems to say that there kind of shouldn't be a next, better
social form.
So it's really hard to square those two.
There is a genuine question moment
to say about the future.
Now, my own view is like, your question gets to the question
of what happened to philosophy after classical German
idealism?
And how do you answer that question as a German idealist?
Because from the German idealist perspective, philosophy,
even if you're not a Hegelian, philosophy
kind of stopped after Hegel.
So Schelling lives much longer than Hegel,
and is actually brought to Hegel by the King of Prussia
to take over what is the Ministry of Education,
to take over Hegel's chair in philosophy in Berlin
to combat the specter of Hegelianism,
because Germans took philosophy really seriously.
And then so the everyday hall Schelling out of,
everyone thinks Schelling is dead,
and he looks like he's dead, but he's still alive.
Yes, something happens to philosophy
from the golden age of classical German philosophy to today,
and people vary in their reactions to it.
If you're a committed German idealist, especially
if you're a Hegelian, you really have
to think that a lot of what happened after Hegel
wasn't philosophy.
Or at least it wasn't moving the ball forward.
It's a repetition of previous things.
Now, does that confirm Hegel's philosophy of history,
or his philosophy of history of philosophy?
Does it refute it?
We'll talk about that when we get there.
And I don't want to, I've already
shown too much of my hand about my own views about these things
that I don't want to give you a lecture on the trappitude
of philosophy since the death of Hegel.
OK, I realize there are other questions,
but I also need to get to the question of,
with what must the beginning of science be made?
OK, so once again, on the handout,
I've outlined the structure, as I interpret it, of this section.
It starts out with some introductory remarks
about the general question of the problem of the beginning
in philosophy, and then it gets an exposition
of the beginning of the science a lot, the pure science.
And then there's some further reflections,
and there's a discussion in Fitbit and other post-contients,
which I will skip.
OK, so the first three paragraphs
introduce the theme of, what is the beginning of philosophy?
Where that can be understood either
as an ontological or metaphysical beginning, what
is the first principle?
Or an epistemological or methodological beginning?
What is our access to that first principle?
How do we methodologically begin in philosophy?
Now, this essay is a response to,
it's an outgrowth of an incredible methodological,
a series of interventions in German philosophy
between Kant and Hegel that become extremely
methodologically self-conscious about what philosophy is
and how to do it, that I won't go into now.
So the project of science of logic, of course,
is to unfold from thought itself the determinations of thought.
So the beginning of logic is the first category or thought
determination of logic.
So the real question here is, what do we begin logically?
Now, should the beginning be immediate,
or should it be immediate?
Now, Hegel begins by telling us that it
can be neither immediate nor immediate,
but then goes on immediately to say
that it is both immediate and immediate.
He says, in fact, that everything under heaven
and on Earth is both immediate and immediate.
So we have to understand what that means.
So I think the mistake is assuming
that if something is immediate, it isn't immediate and vice
versa, because if that were the case,
then the claim that everything was immediate and immediate
would be a contradiction.
And it wouldn't be a contradiction
that, so to speak, Hegel takes away or revolves.
It would just be left with a contradiction.
So what do we mean by mediation?
Now, there's at least three senses of mediation
that are relevant.
What I call on the handout, metaphysical mediation,
epistemic mediation, and semantic mediation.
And the idea of mediation, I'm looking for the definition,
I put a note about the definition of mediation
in the encyclopedias, but I won't find it in a moment.
Here it is.
This is page 40 in the encyclopediologic reading.
I'll just read it out loud.
It's a very short sentence.
Mediation means to make a beginning
and then to have proceeded to a second item,
such that this second item is the way it is only
insofar as one has arrived at it by starting with something
that is an other over against it.
So mediation means there's two things,
and one of them is arrived at by means of,
and is therefore distinct from, the other.
So metaphysical mediation would be something like x,
one thing is in virtue of another,
or it ontologically depends upon another,
or as we now say is grounded in another.
Epistemic mediation would be knowing something
by means of knowing something else.
The classic example would be inferring something
from something else.
And semantic mediation would be that something
has its meaning, or is the content it is,
in virtue of its relation to something else.
That would be something like a definition.
So bachelor is semantically mediated by unmarried.
If these two concepts are defined in relation
to one another, they're mutually mediated.
Now what would a presupposition be?
It would be something that isn't mediated by something else.
So a metaphysi, sorry, it would be something
that is mediated by something else.
So something is a metaphysical presupposition
if it grounds something else.
It's an epistemic presupposition
if it allows you to know something.
It's a semantic presupposition
if it allows you to define something else.
So if something were presuppositionless,
it would have to be metaphysically ungrounded,
epistemically immediate, and semantically immediate.
Okay, now what is the relevant notion of mediation,
and therefore beginning for Hegel?
Well, in some sense, one and three are identical in the lot.
Because we know something by means
of its semantic relationships
of some other thought content.
A thought content is what it is via its semantic relations.
So semantic and metaphysical dependency go together
with one another with respect to things
that are essentially semantic, essentially thought contents.
And likewise, in the logic, we would assume
that we know things via that which defines them.
But I wanna focus on the third
because we're focused on thought contents.
Okay, so the project of the logic has to be,
means that we have to begin with an immediate thought content.
The first category of the logic
has to be an immediate thought context
because the project is to unfold all the contents
of thinking from thinking itself.
If it began with a thought content A
that was semantically mediated by something else B,
that is to say, it was the thought content
and it was via B or was defined in terms of B,
then we should have started with B.
B would be the true beginning of the logic.
Okay, so we need a immediate beginning for the logic.
Immediate beginning for the logic.
So the beginning of the logic
has to be an immediate thought content.
Okay, so, Hegel gives a little argument at 21.55
for what the beginning of logic should be.
This is,
is it 25.55?
So it's actually 25.56.
It's basically the paragraph that begins,
being is what makes the beginning here and then ends,
the beginning is there for a pure being.
But I think actually we can just skip most of that paragraph
and just focus on the last two sentences,
which I have on the handout.
Just as it cannot have any determination
with respect to another, the beginning,
so to it cannot have any within it.
It cannot have any content,
or any content would entail distinction
and the reference of distinct moments to each other
and hence a mediation.
The beginning is therefore pure being.
Okay, so here's my reconstruction
of how Hegel is reasoning there.
The beginning has to be immediate.
If it were determined, that is to say,
we're either internally determined,
it has parts that are determined with respect to another,
or if it was determinate with respect
to something distinct from it, it would be immediate.
Why?
Because determinacy, to be a specific determinate thing,
requires not being something else.
And determinacy is a, sorry,
this is slightly less precise than I would have liked.
Let me just articulate this, okay.
So the beginning must be immediate.
Because if it were not, that which mediates it
would be a true beginning.
If it is immediate, then it is indeterminate.
Why?
Because determinacy entails negation.
Because determinacy is to be one thing
rather than something else.
And that requires not being or negation.
Or in other words, Hegel is appealing to
the Spittisist principle,
omnis determinatio,
as negatio.
Okay, this appears in letter 50
of Spinoza to a guy named Jorig Yellis.
So if you want your name to live in eternity,
and you don't think you have it in you
to write one of the great works
of the history of philosophy,
make sure that one of the great philosophers
of all time writes you a letter.
And then for now until eternity,
people will mention your name.
Jorig Yellis, lost history.
I mention this guy's name in like every class I teach.
He will live forever.
Is it not letter 50?
No, it is, I have a question.
Oh, you know, sorry.
Okay, no.
Spinoza doesn't put the word omnisig.
That's an interpolation.
I think it's interpretively correct.
I think it's very clear in context.
He doesn't just say determination is negation.
He means all determination is negation.
Okay.
So the beginning has to be completely indeterminate.
Okay, that is to say if it's completely indeterminate,
if something isn't something else,
it's also determinate.
It's not that thing.
It's not just that determinacy entails negation.
They're the same.
So the beginning of logic has to be
not only completely indeterminate,
but completely non-negated.
What is pure science about?
It's about the content of things.
What does thought think about?
It talks about being.
So the first category of the logic
has to be completely indeterminate, non-negated being.
Completely indeterminate, immediacy.
That is to say it's not a thought about this being
or that being, this kind of being, this way of being.
It's just being.
Or as Hegel sometimes characterizes it, purity.
That means there's a thematic connection
between the beginning of the logic and sense certainty.
So one of the things we'll eventually have to talk about
is what exactly is the relationship
between the beginning of logic and sense certainty.
And I am not entirely sure what I think about that.
Hojo and then you.
Yes, so premise one, would you say it's descriptive
or is it normative?
And also is premise one itself a first principle
or is it further justified?
It's further justified because what we're doing here,
we're not doing logic yet.
All of these are external remarks
because none of this stuff has been derived in logic.
We're all just kind of fancy-footin'.
This is all just like, you know.
Hegel's like, it's not that he doesn't want to start sign
pure thinking.
It's like he's delaying the beginning of as long as possible
so that you have as much preparation as possible
before we dive right in and think purity.
Yes.
Two questions.
So can we say negation is pure supposition,
this is first, and the second question,
the beginning is pure being.
Can we say the pure being is I and I is perception?
No, no I, no perception.
However, there is a connection
because the first principle of fixtus philosophy is I
and Hegel thinks that's just as indeterminate
as pure being.
And so fixtus to be congratulated
with a completely indeterminate starting point.
But A, it's not absolute
because being an I or being a subject,
it's defined through what it isn't,
namely the object.
So we're not yet at a completely presuppositionless
or absolute starting point.
And the way fixtus system of philosophy works,
when we start with that starting point,
we can't get any further.
And Hegel thinks his system is set up in such a way
that we can get further than purity.
Yeah.
Oh sorry, okay, yeah.
So can we say negation is pure supposition?
I don't wanna go so far as to say
that negation and presupposition are always the same thing.
If I presuppose something,
then there's what's being presupposed
and what that presupposition supports, so to speak,
what's supposed.
There's the supposition and the presupposition.
They have to be different.
And so they have to be determinate
with respect to one another.
So wherever there's presupposition, there is negation.
I wouldn't wanna go so far as to say that negation
always involves presupposition of all being.
Yeah.
So far, in the short argument for idealism
or for thought, has it come from being kind of
as like the assumption of our collection of all being?
I didn't, that's your interpretation, I didn't say that.
Okay.
Being is definitely not a collection of all being.
Because then being would be a being.
And there would be the following question.
Is there a being beyond that collection?
Namely, a being beyond being, and that's incoherent.
Except, I should know there are all these people.
There's this tradition, as some of you know very well,
of thinking that the form of the good
in play that would be beyond being.
So it's not a being.
I can't really make any sense of that.
Yeah, how do you think?
So is immediacy related to your own collection?
And what does immediacy, immediacy, distinction
relate to at the beginning?
They're related, but they're not identical.
So if there's a condition and a condition,
then they're distinct and they're determinate
partly in relation to one another.
To be a condition is to be the condition
of some condition, which you are not.
To be a condition just to be conditioned by something,
to have a condition that you are not.
So those are determinate and they have all negation.
But not all determinacy negation relations
are conditioning relations.
Because a conditioning relation is asymmetric.
So I don't think it's right to say
that these condition relationships.
So conditioning relations, asymmetric relations
of ontological dependence, become the topic of the logic.
They don't start out as the topic of the logic.
They're the topic of the doctrine of essence,
the second of the third parts of the logic.
Yes?
Can you just say that the beginning
of being immediate and distinguish
from the immediate is therefore just a meaning?
That is exactly the problem that we'll talk about next week.
That is the problem on which the entire Hegelian enterprise
potentially falters.
And everyone's been worried about this
since Schelling, his former college roommate,
was kind enough to point this out in public.
Yes?
So we haven't actually started the science of logic
problem yet.
No.
You have not thought purely yet.
So we start presumable.
I know that was not meant personally.
For all I know, you think you're real.
So we start with being pure being in the actual science of logic.
So this argument doesn't really serve any purpose
besides to convince ourselves as the reader that OK.
Yes.
What exactly is the problem of needing a beginning?
I think I just lost a step.
OK.
We want to do pure science.
Yeah.
We have to start somewhere.
The starting point has to be scientifically determined.
It can't be arbitrary.
Because if it were arbitrary, where we get
might depend on where we started.
And if where we get is arbitrary, if it's just like,
this is a plausible starting point, then where we get might be arbitrary.
And that it wouldn't be scientific.
OK.
Yes.
Hagle have any friends?
Sorry.
Yes.
He was actually a super fun guy.
Well, if it's on contemporaries, they're thinking of empirical scientists.
We're talking about absolute knowledge.
Were there any empirical scientists who went, hey, there's something in this
that we ought to know about?
Yes.
But I don't know enough about it.
So Hagle is intimately acquainted with and involved
with the empirical natural science of his day.
Knows it as well as it's possible for anyone
to know all of the sciences of the 19th century.
And in fact, what's the main thing that Hagle
does in the second edition of The Doctrine and Being?
It's not addressed the problem about the beginning of the logic
that everyone has been worried about.
He seems to think there's no problem.
So either there's no problem or Hagle is the worst
philosopher of the 19th century.
What does he primarily do?
He massively updates the treatment of calculus in The Doctrine and Being.
So there's this enormous digression about the mathematics of the infinite
in the first half of the science of logic.
Here's the problem.
Historical mathematics is weird.
The calculus you learned in your calculus class
is cleaned up post-Vierstrass, post-Dedekind presentations of calculus.
When you read historical calculus texts, they're fucking wild.
And they do things in this completely unnatural geometric way.
Because they don't have a rigorous definition of a limit.
They don't have a digorous definition of continuity.
So they've got to do it with this kind of jiggery-pogory.
And Hagle has read all of the relevant books
by Lagrange and everybody and is completely fully up to date with it
and writes this super long digression about how only his metaphysics of quantity
explains properly what the quantitative infinite is.
And otherwise, you can't do calculus properly.
So if you want this class to take a really weird 90-degree term, OK.
That'll be it.
I'll see you next week.
Can I ask, you can ask all the questions.
Why is this called German idealism when it seems like such an extreme realism?
So Marcus Gabriel, his joke about this is the English translation of idealism is realism.
Now, the reason is, as we see.